neue corona hotspots in deutschland vor
allem großstädte melden immer mehr fälle
und beschließen unterschiedliche
maßnahmen feuerpause für berg karabach
armenien und aserbaidschan beschließen
eine waffenruhe frieden scheint aber
weit entfernt
diktator kim lässt sich feiern mit einer
großen militärparade begeht nordkorea
den 75 jahrestag der parteigründung
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten mit üppigen
samstag sport und norbert lehmann dem
erfolg des deutschen doppels bei den
french open dazu später mehr
es kommt wie vorhergesagt mit beginn des
herbstes schießen die korona
neuinfektionen wieder in die höhe
und wir alle müssen uns auf weitere
einschränkungen gefasst machen je nach
lage vor ort doch damit wird es immer
unübersichtlicher in deutschland auch
weil jeden tag woanders ein neues
risikogebiet dazu kommt heute meldet das
robert-koch-institut 4721 neue fälle
noch mal 200 mehr als gestern
der trend nach oben zu sehen auch am
sieben tage schnitt demnach haben sich
täglich 3160 menschen neu mit dem virus
angesteckt die zahl der verstorbenen
liegt im selben zeitraum
durchschnittlich bei 12 pro tag schauen
wir auf die regionen da hat neben
großstädten wie berlin bremen und
frankfurt am main nun auch köln den
kritischen wert von 50 neuinfektionen
pro 100000 einwohner überschritten ist
also risikogebiet anselm stern berichtet
die nächste metropole der nächste
offizielle virus hotspot samt neuen
strengen regeln kontakt beschränkungen
alkoholverbote masken pflicht in der
fußgängerzone jetzt auch in köln
dem was geht es auch ganz gut um andere
leute zu schützen hätte man vielleicht
auch schon mal drauf kommen können was
sein muss muss sein und dann finde ich
natürlich auch zur sicherheit von allen
die verantwortung tragen wir alle dann
finde ich das auch so insgesamt diese
verschiedenen vorschriften mal so und
mal so
das verunsicherte er ganz besonders
umstritten das beherbergungs verbot für
die die aus einem sogenannten
risikogebiet kommen bundesweit sollte es
gelten daraus wurde nichts
beispiel wer aus berlin nach mecklenburg
vorpommern reist muss auf jeden fall in
quarantäne
geht es nach thüringen geht das nicht
beherbergungs verbote stellen eingriffe
in grundrechte dar von hoteliers von
reisenden diese können aber rechtmäßig
seien gegen die rechtmäßigkeit spricht
ist wenn es sehr pauschale regelung gibt
also urlauber zum beispiel von einem
gesamten landkreis betroffen sind
obwohl der korona ausbruch innerhalb
dieses landkreises nur einer kleinen
region ist für die rechtmäßigkeit
spricht es das mit einem negativen
kroner test in der tasche der urlaub
möglich ist reise regel flickenteppich
mitten in der ferienzeit unverständlich
und ungerecht sagen die hotels und
gaststätten die wieder neue einbußen
fürchten
scharfe kritik kommt aber auch von
ärzten und virologen die hotspots ändern
sich täglich
es ist also völlig unübersichtlich wann
kann man wohl noch hin reisen zum einen
können sie es kaum überprüfen und herum
reisende familien in deutschland sind
sie nicht die treiber desinfektions
geschehens das sind ganz andere events
wie zum beispiel große hochzeit mit
mehreren hundert teilnehmern die energie
die man jetzt verschwendet um diese
reise geschichte irgendwie ja vernünftig
hin zu bekommen sollte man darauf
verwenden eigentlich die hauptquelle der
neuinfektionen in den griff zu bekommen
und das sind für primär private feiern
zusammen seien reisen erholen
unbeschwert nur schwer möglich in diesem
herbst in deutschland
wie wir inzwischen wissen ist die lage
in den großstädten entscheidend im kampf
gegen korona wenn da begegnen sich
besonders viele menschen auf engem raum
schauen wir mal genauer auf zwei solche
hotspots andrea meuser hat sich in
frankfurt am main umgeschaut
zuvor aber berichten lisa
und nils schneider aus berlin
polizeikontrolle der neuen sperrstunde
in berlin neukölln
ob bar restaurant oder kristalle müssen
von 23 bis 6 uhr schließen
einige reagieren erst als die beamten da
sind genauso am rosenthaler platz in
berlin-mitte von einer sperrstunde
halten die nachtschwärmer nichts also
wenn da macht man das risiko oder gar
nicht aber so 3.20 uhr sie fragen ob er
jetzt ist vorbei kein wenn wir woanders
kaufen nach hause gehen darf ein coup
der strom hier ist dass es einfach
komplett sinnlos
andere halten sich an die regeln der
kreuzberger bar das hotel ok lieben es
ist jetzt wirklich ja wir haben jetzt
noch zehn minuten zeit
die neuen regeln könnten das ende seiner
bar bedeuten der chef findet die
sperrstunde würde die falschen treffen
prinzipiell die leute die versuchen die
regeln einzuhalten
in den gleichen topf geschmissen werden
wie die leute die die regel eben
überhaupt gar nicht einhalten und
ich hätte mir gewünscht dass es einfach
mehr kontrolle des berliner bezirks
politiker halten die sperrstunde für ein
wichtiges signal
es brauche kontrolle und
eigenverantwortung was man nicht
gewährleisten kann in einer
demokratischen gesellschaft ist das
sieht vor jeder haustüre ordnungskraft
zu stehen haben das ist nicht möglich
sondern in einer demokratischen
gesellschaft ist man auf die bürgerinnen
und bürger angewiesen
genau dafür gibt es ja auch jetzt die
vorgaben zum zum alltäglichen verhalten
und die kontrollen sind schon seit märz
besonders hoch vor der kreuzberger bar
sehen sie dass so ein luxusproblem sich
darüber zu beschweren dass wir jetzt
etwas früher nach hause gehen müssen
solidarisch sein und doch irgendwie sein
leben leben ist die gastronomen hoffen
dass sie die nächsten wochen überleben
draußen zusammen sein essen und trinken
das darf man in frankfurt am main auch
ohne maske und zwar überall
hauptsache der abstand wird eingehalten
durch die größte einkaufsstraße der
stadt schlendern das aber geht nur mit
masken solchen maske tragen zu erklären
wie wir das hier ist niemand weit und
breit kann ich habe meine abend fünf
meter ausstrecken ich finds halt
verantwortungslos von anderen dafür hat
keine tragen müsste viel mehr publik
gemacht werden mir fehlen noch
ordnungskräfte einfach die ganz
friedlich rumlaufen in leute rinne
masten pflicht in bestimmten straßen
alkoholverbot an einigen plätzen das
alles gehört zu frankfurts 9 anti corona
maßnahmen und auch die sperrstunde ab 23
uhr
diese auflagen sind dem geschuldet dass
wir wissen dass insbesondere
feierlichkeiten gaststätten clubs
tanzveranstaltungen mittlerweile zur
weiterverbreitung dieses virus beitragen
er ist doch ein trugschluss zu glauben
dass um 23 uhr das kuscheln oder der
alkoholkonsum aufhören
das verlagert sich nur in private räume
widersprüche und unsicherheiten bei
denen die jetzt nicht mehr so lange
feiern dürfen
ich weiß nicht ob so viel bringt also 23
10 euro
ja ist also kann man es machen noch
steigen die zahlen in frankfurt genauso
wie in offenbach der kampf gegen korona
er entscheidet sich wohl vor allem in
den metropolen
besonders viele neue infektionen werden
derzeit allerdings in delmenhorst
nachgewiesen die knapp 80.000 einwohner
stadt in niedersachsen entwickelt sich
gerade zum corona hotspot warum das
können sich die behörden nicht richtig
erklären
es habe in mehreren familien fälle
gegeben das ganze habe sich dann wohl
ausgeweitet das gesundheitsamt macht
inzwischen sonderschichten dort wurden
allein von gestern auf heute 26 neue
fälle registriert in delmenhorst also
viele infizierte anderswo sind die
zahlen niedrig wie sich die lage in
ihrer region entwickelt staat zu finden
sie zahlen und grafiken jederzeit in
unserer zdf heute app mittlerweile
steigt die zahl der korona neuinfektion
in
fast allen europäischen ländern stark an
gestern hatte die
weltgesundheitsorganisation zum ersten
mal mehr als hunderttausend neue fälle
in europa registriert in spanien und
frankreich wird überlegt den notstand zu
verhängen in deutschland gibt es im
schnitt der letzten sieben tage 38 fälle
auf 100000 einwohner in spanien sind es
280 in frankreich 236 heiko pisa
berichtet 20 1339 neue fälle in 24
stunden so viele gab es in frankreich
noch nie
sorge bereite die lage in den pariser
krankenhäusern dort nimmt der anteil der
gruppe die 19 patienten auf den
intensivstationen zu steigende
fallzahlen gibt es auch in belgien und
in den niederlanden in der schweiz sieht
es mit 81 fällen auf 100000 einwohner
noch vergleichsweise gut aus österreich
meldet einen anstieg auf 116 immer
dramatischer wird die lage aber in
tschechien mit 370 bestätigten fällen
allein gestern kam er als 8600 neu dazu
3300 mehr als einen tag zuvor
sportstätten sind geschlossen ab montag
gilt das auch für theater kinos und
museen ministerpräsident barbisch hat
einen kompletten lockdown ins gespräch
gebracht präsident seemann widerspricht
dem heute und bekommt unterstützung aus
der wirtschaft
zwei wochen halten wir das durch länger
ist es nicht zu schaffen
71 infektionen auf 100000 einwohner
meldet polen aber auch mit mehr als
5.000 neun fällen an einem tag so viele
wie nie zuvor seit heute gilt hier eine
maske pflicht auch im freien
ich bin ärztin es wird schwierig für
unsere krankenhäuser treffen mit
freunden sollten eingeschränkt werden
damit es schnell vorbei ist ab
donnerstag dürfen senioren in polen nur
noch zu festgelegten zeiten einkaufen
gehen die neueste vorsichtsmaßnahme
ja/nein von angesicht zu angesicht oder
doch virtuell seit der cobit erkrankung
von us-präsident trump wurde viel
spekuliert wie die zweite tv debatte mit
herausforderer joe biden mitte des
monats
aussehen könnte nun ist klar sie wird
abgesagt am 22 oktober sollen sich der
republikaner und der demokraten in
tennessee noch einmal direkt
gegenüberstehen
in der südkaukasus region berg karabach
gilt seit dem mittag eigentlich eine
waffenruhe
doch sie scheint brüchig dabei hatten
sich die außenminister armeniens und
aserbaidschans erst in der nacht in
moskau auf die feuerpause geeinigt
berg karabach gehört völkerrechtlich zum
islamisch geprägten aserbaidschan
die selbsternannten republik wird jedoch
überwiegend von christlichen armeniern
bewohnt ende september war der konflikt
um die region wieder aufgeflammt für
begabte rätselt arthur diskutiert was
für ein geschoss war es wohl dass seine
geburtstagsfeier so jäh unterbrach
weswegen seine freunde und verwandte auf
die straße liefen um ihr leben fürchten
hier haben wir gegessen zeigte auf die
überreste seiner wohnung ist der panda
kennt diese bilder wurden vor der
waffenruhe in bergkarabach aufgenommen
stehen stellvertretend für unzählige
zerstörte häuser
tausende menschen die durch die kämpfe
der letzten tage alles verloren haben
die verfeindeten nachbarn armenien und
aserbaidschan an den verhandlungstisch
zu bringen ist ein erfolg moskaus zehn
stunden wurde gerungen bis tief in die
vergangene nacht um punkt zwölf uhr am
10 oktober tritt eine waffenruhe in
kraft für humanitäre zwecke nutzen für
den austausch von kriegs- und anderen
gefangenen sowie für die überführung der
körper der verstorbenen hübschen
russland vermittelt und ist gleichzeitig
schutzmacht armenien aserbaidschan weist
die türkei an seiner seite
der konflikt um berg-karabach ist
brisant und besonders schwer zu
entwirren da schon seit jahrzehnten um
das territorium gestritten und gekämpft
wird heute mittag zählt in bergkarabach
etwas anderes
wir müssen unsere toten abholen ein
naher verwandter von mir ist in der
leichenhalle
wir werden ihnen morgen bei setzen die
sirenen verraten ist die feuerpause hält
nicht schon um kurz nach zwölf werfen
sich aserbaidschan und armenien
gegenseitig verstöße wurden die
waffenruhe brüchig
ein friedensabkommen nicht mal in sicht
sein land sei völlig frei von corona
sagt nordkoreas diktator kim jong un nur
dürfe dürfte es außerhalb des verarmten
landes kaum jemand glauben zum 75
geburtstag der kommunistischen partei
entschuldigte er sich zwar für das harte
leben in nordkorea inszenierte aber auch
die vermeintliche stärke mit einer
nächtlichen militär parallel freuler
berichtet kim jong-un muss unter tränen
seine rede unterbrechen so gerührt dass
der diktator von der liebe seines volkes
und dessen opferbereitschaft die
wirtschaft liegt am boden corona hat das
land noch weiter isoliert kim
entschuldigt sich dafür bei seinem volk
meine hingabe war nicht ausreichend um
unser volk aus den schwierigen
lebensbedingungen herauszubringen
eine glitzer show soll darüber
hinwegtäuschen dass die internationalen
sanktionen nordkorea schwer zusetzen
aber dennoch will kim jong-un sein
atomwaffenprogramm nicht aufgeben auf
der parade wurden laut experten neue
langstreckenwaffen gezeigt das militär
ist die lebensversicherung für die kim
diktatur kim hat die partei und das
militär in seiner amtszeit gestärkt so
gelingt es ihm seine herrschaft in einer
gewissen weise zu stabilisieren die
parade zeigt genau das was nordkorea
zeigen will
ein volk das seinen anführer kim innig
liebt und ein land das wohl kleinere
atomwaffen besitzt und entschlossen ist
sie im notfall einzusetzen nordkorea
bleibt unberechenbar und gefährlich
die macht von kim jong-un scheint weiter
uneingeschränkt zu sein das
hochgerüstete land hört auf sein
kommando nach berlin dort gab es bei
einer demonstration gegen die räumung
des besetzten hauses liebigstr der nacht
randale
dabei flogen feuerwerkskörper steine und
flaschen auf polizisten
auch mehrere autos wurden angezündet
etwa 1900 einsatzkräfte waren vor ort
das haus galt als symbol der
linksradikalen szene nach langem streit
war es gestern unter protest geräumt
worden
tja und nun zu dir norbert und zum sieg
des deutschen herren doppels bei kevin
krawietz und andreas mieth er amis haben
es geschafft ihren titel wieder zu
verteidigen das ganze vor 15 minuten und
zwar gegen den kroaten mate pavic und
den brasilianer bruno soares mit 6 3 und
7 zu 5
die beiden freunde kevin krawietz und
andreas mies zeigen von beginn an einen
imposanten siegeswillen und bei uns sich
gegenseitig immer wieder auch gegen mate
pavic und bruno soares die amtierenden
us open champions zeigt sich das beste
deutsche doppel in den entscheidenden
momenten selbstbewusst und clever ein
grand-slam-turnier zu gewinnen ist
schwer aber noch schwerer ist es einen
erfolg im jahr darauf zu bestätigen
und genau das gelingt kevin krawietz und
andreas mies glatt in zwei sätzen mit 6
3 und 7 zu 5 machen sich die french open
champions von 2009 10 auch zu denen von
2020 und eine frostige tennis
überraschung in paris gab es auch die 19
jährige senkrechtstarterin gas sonntag
aus polen gewinnt mit gewinnt die french
open sie besiegt so viel erkennen aus
den usa mit 6 zu 4 und 6 zu 1 zur
formel1 morgen der große preis der eifel
auf dem nürburgring heute das qualifying
und wieder dominiert mercedes walter
roboters startet als schnellster
von der pole position vor seinem
kollegen weltmeister lewis hamilton
dritter max verstappen im red bull der
lange im qualifying vorne lag besser
nicht es heute für schale claire im
ferrari mit platz vier sein teamkollege
sebastian vettel dagegen startet beim
heim-grand-prix nur von position ist und
heute abend nations league die dfb elf
tritt in kiew gegen die ukraine an die
gastgebermannschaft wegen corona fällen
geschwächt die deutschen gäste dagegen
in topbesetzung auch torwart manuel
neuer ist nach längerer pause wieder
dabei nach fast einem jahr kehrt manuel
neuer ins tor der nationalelf zurück der
kapitän will mithelfen dass die seit
drei spielen sieglose mannschaft wieder
in den erfolgs rhythmus kommt freuen uns
auf das spiel gegen die ukraine und sind
heiß und wollen natürlich den ersten
sieg auch einfahren
der ukrainische teamchef schewtschenko
muss aufgrund von corona fällen und
verletzungen auf 14 spieler verzichten
aber es ist immer sehr unangenehme
mannschaft die auch gute techniker in
den eigenen reihen haben die natürlich
auch in der defensive auch die es die
eine oder andere schwachstelle haben die
wir ausnutzen möchte
entgegen der ursprünglichen planung
werden sie direkt nach dem spiel die
heimreise aus dem chor ohne risikogebiet
antreten
in köln geht es dann am dienstag gegen
die schweiz wahrscheinlich ohne
zuschauer wegen der stark gestiegenen
kinderzahlen in köln haben wir wollen
gehört
danke ganz unterschiedlich wird das
wetter morgen von sonnenschein bis hin
zu gewittern ist alles dabei
die details hat gleich ist intelli so
viele von uns das heute journal mit
marietta slomka um drei viertel 11 und
wir sind morgen abend wieder für sie da
punkt 7 wir danken für ihr interesse und
wünschen ein schönes wochenende
tschüss
[Musik]
ein schön genannte und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter das tief über der
nordsee das verlagert sich langsam nach
nordosten und dabei kommt auf seiner
rückseite etwas kühlere luft und auch
schauer sind dabei die kühlere luft
bekommen wir vor allem in der nacht zu
spüren ja und da kommen schon von
nordwesten wolken mit regen ansonsten
ist es in der mitte meist trocken und es
klart auf nach süden hin gibt es
ebenfalls regen an der donau nebel und
dort wo es aufklart da wird es durchaus
auch mal frostig zum beispiel richtung
vogtland im südwesten ein grad und an
der nordsee 8 grad morgen im
tagesverlauf gibt es weitere schauer
ganz im westen und richtung ostsee
einige gewitter ziehen von der nordsee
dazwischen wieder sonnige abschnitte und
ganz im süden ebenfalls kompakte
bewölkung am alpenrand mittring
temperaturen erreichen 7 grad dort und
13 grad zum beispiel im
rhein-main-gebiet 14 richtung sachsen
anhalt der blick auf die nächsten tage
zeigt uns es gibt einige schauer vor
allem am montag nach westen bei 7 bis 14
grad die darauf folgenden tage bleiben
ähnlich bei den temperaturen und einige
schauer am dienstag ein schöner abend